THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
REAL [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
BY CASSIE.
WINNER [inaudible]
WILK.
SENATORS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WHAT THE MEMBERS ARE GAS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE'RE GONNA BE
LEADING FOR THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN REVEREND
ALAIN WHITE FEATHER. FOUR WINS
MINISTRY AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE'RE GONNA BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR HER TALK.
THE GREAT SPIRIT CREATOR MOTHER
FATHER GOD. ONE WHO IS KNOWN BY
MANY NAMES I OFFER MY GRATITUDE
FOR OUR LIVES IN FOR OUR LIFE'S
JOURNEY.
ISEND MY VOICE THIS DAY ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRED GATHERING
OF LEADERS. FOR ALL THE HOOPS
THEY SHALL BE TOUCHED BY WHAT IS
DONE HERE IN THIS HOLY PLACE AND
FOR THIS NOW MOMENT WE HAVE ALL
BEEN CALLED TO ANSWER.
I CALL UPON THE ANCESTRAL SPIRIT
OF OUR PEOPLE WHOSE STRINGS ARE
PASSED DOWN TO EACH OF US HERE
THAT WE MIGHT WALK IN WISDOM FOR
THE WHOLE.
THAT YOU WILL GUIDE EACH
INDIVIDUALLY AND COLLECTIVELY TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR ACTIONS HARM
NO ONE AND BENEFIT EVERYONE.
I PRAY THAT EVERY BREATH AND
HEART BEAT OF EACH LAWMAKER WILL
WEAVE TOGETHER RESPECT TRUTH
HONOR INTEGRITY TO CREATE
GREATER UNITY AND EQUALITY FOR
THE EVOLUTION OF OUR STATE.
I LET THEM FEET.
LET THEM FEET HOPE AND WALK WITH
FATE CREATOR FOR TODAY THEY HOLD
THE HOPE FAITH AND TRUST OF US
ALL.
I ASK THAT YOU BLESS THEM FOR
THEY ARE THE ONES WE HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR A MAN.
AND A MAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
WELCOME BACK MEMBERS WE HAVE
THREE RESOLUTIONS ON OUR DOCKET
HERE TODAY.
WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE IN
OUR SESSION.
IN RECOGNIZE ANY MEMBERS AND
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA BE MOVING FORWARD WITH
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THOSE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
SENATORS WERE NOW ADVANCING TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
ANY SENATOR WISHING TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK ON TO THE SIDE.
AARON SEEN NINE WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE MOVING FOR TO INTRODUCTION
AND FIRST READING OF BILLS
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE
SIXTY SIX ONE SIXTY SEVEN ONE
SIXTY EIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE ONE
SEVENTY TWO BILLS OF LADING READ
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SECRETARY.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE NOW ON
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP FILE ITEMS
ONE TWO IN.
THREE WE'D LIKE TO GET A LOOK TO
SENATOR GLAZER.
BETTER SEE IF HE'S PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
HE'LL TEMPORARY PASS ON FILE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR LABOR FILE ITEM TO YOU
PREPARE TO PRESENT.
CENTER LEYVA IS MISTER SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION ELEVEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AWARENESS MONTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE FLOORS YOUR
SENATOR GOOD AFTERNOON MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION.
ELEVEN S. R. ELEVEN RECOGNIZES
JANUARY AS HUMAN TRIBE FORMULA
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
A YEAR CRIMINAL INDUSTRY THAT
DENIES FREEDOM TO MORE THAN
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD INCLUDING CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST INCIDENCES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE NATION
BECAUSE OF ITS MAJOR AIRPORTS
HARBOURS COASTLINES.
INTERNATIONAL BORDERS ECONOMY
AND IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE NATIONAL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HOTLINE
RECEIVED OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND CALLS.
OF THOSE CALLS ALMOST FOUR
THOUSAND PER FROM CALIFORNIA
THAT IS THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
CALLS IN THE NATION.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY PEOPLE ARE
UNAWARE THAT THIS IS HAPPENING
IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES AS
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE WE
MUST REMAIN AWARE OF THIS MODERN
FORM OF SLAVERY.
THIS STILL HAPPENS ACROSS OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ESTARá LET
THE LEVIN WILL BRING AWARENESS
TO THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND HELP
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN OF ALL AGES.
BUT PATH PASSING AS OUR ELEVEN
TODAY CALIFORNIA'S TAKING
AFFIRMATIVE STANCE TO HELP
PREVENT A TO HELP PREVENT AND
ELIMINATE HUMAN TRAFFICKING ONCE
AND FOR ALL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENATORS LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR IF WE
COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
FROM THE FLOOR OVER TO LEADER
BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT HIGH
TO RISE SIDE TO SUPPORT SENATE
RESOLUTION ELEVEN UNFORTUNATELY
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S BEST
ATTRIBUTES.
LIKE OUR COASTLINE AND THRIVING
ECONOMY MAKE IT A HUB FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN FACT OVER A
QUARTER OF FEDERAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES ARE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN WHICH VICTIMS ARE
ECONOMICALLY EXPLOITED THROUGH
PROSTITUTION DOMESTIC SERVICE
AGRICULTURE AND SWEATSHOP WERE.
ALTHOUGH ORANGE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SEE SOME OF THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CASES WE ALSO HAVE MANY GENEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE WAY MAKERS.
WHO ARE DEDICATED TO SERVING THE
VICTIMS OF THESE CRIMES?
I HAVE BEEN A PLEASED TO BE PART
OF A SEVERAL BIPARTISAN EFFORTS
TO REDUCE HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
OUR STATE.
THAT HAVE SAID WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO SO I SUPPORT
THE REVELATION RESOLUTION ASKS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
US IN OUR CONTINUED FIGHT. TO
END ON THIS.
TERRIBLE CRIME HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THANK YOU THANK YOU LEADER BATES.
MEMBERS ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
RUBIO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS PRESIDENT
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR
ELEVEN IS HEART WRENCHING THAT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN I STILL STAND
BEFORE YOU SPEAKING ABOUT THIS
DEVASTATING ISSUE.
THIS MODERN FORM OF SLAVERY HAS
BEEN RECOGNIZED AS A GROWING UP
A DIVE EPIDEMIC BY THE UNITED
NATIONS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED ONE OF THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF REPORTED CASES AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED.
AND AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS A GROWING
EPIDEMIC IN OUR COMMUNITIES IT
IS DESTROYING LIVES AND TEARING
GENERATIONS OF FAMILIES APART.
ONE MAN ARE ALSO VICTIMS OF
HUMAN OF THOSE AFFECTED ARE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN OF WHICH MORE
THAN HALF THE VICTIMS ARE
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED.
COLLEAGUES WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS
TO PERSIST WE MUST WORK TOGETHER
TO DISMANTLE TRAFFICKING AND
HELP SURVIVORS SURVIVORS REBUILD
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR
LIVES I ALSO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ESTARá ELEVEN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN A RUBIO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS --
THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR THIS
RESOLUTION TO THE FLOOR I WORK
WITH TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING --
ORGANIZATIONS MOSTLY NON PROFITS
IN THE DISTRICT IN AROUND THE
STATE.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE KERN COUNTY
IS LIKE A GATEWAY SO FROM THE
NORTH TO SOUTH AND EAST TO WEST
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THROUGH --
THROUGH GOING THROUGH TO VEGAS
OR DOWN SOUTH TO SAN DIEGO IT'S
IT'S LIKE A STOPPING GROUND IN
MY DAUGHTER WHO ACTUALLY IS IN
THE BUILDING SOMEPLACE TODAY.
I CAME TO MY HOUSE ONE NIGHT SHE
WAS MOM GET HAPPY.
AND I'M LIKE WHY HIM SHE WAS WE
HAVE TO GO GET THIS LITTLE GIRL
SHE'S TWELVE YEARS OLD HE'S ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD ON UNION
AVENUE.
AND I SAID WELL WE'RE NOT GOING
THAT WILL MAKE PHONE CALLS SO WE
CONTACTED OUR LOCAL SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND THEY REALLY DID.
WHO GET THIS TWELVE YEAR OLD
GIRL OFF THE STREETS OF
BAKERSFIELD ON UNION AVENUE AND
SHE WAS BROUGHT FROM BACK EAST?
TO BE PART OF THE SUPERBOWL --
THE EVENTS THAT TAKE PLACE WHERE
THE ALL OVER THE STATE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SUPPORTING OF PRE
ACTIVITY THINGS I GUESS IS WHAT
YOU'D CALL IT.
SO I I DO A JUST APPLY THE
AUTHOR FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
WOMEN IN MAKING SURE NOT ONLY
MEN BUT WITH WOMEN AND MEN.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN OUR STATE
AND ACROSS THIS NATION AND I
JUST APPLY THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
MEMBERS ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR
WINNER [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER PRESIDENT BECAUSE I RISE
IN SUPPORT --
ON BEHALF OF THE LGBT CAUCUS OF
AS ARE A LOT AND R. O. G. TOO
YOUNG PEOPLE IN PARTICULARLY IN
PARTICULAR ARE AT SIGNIFICANT
RISK OF BEING TRAFFICKED WE KNOW
THAT 40% --
OF HOMELESS USE --
ARE LGBT AT IS A IT'S A BIG A
BIG CHALLENGE --
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR USE AND
PROBLEMS AND WE'RE WORKING VERY
HARD TO TRY.
TO HELP THEM AND AND GET THEM ON
A GOOD PATH IN LIFE --
LGBT USE OUR EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT RATES OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE --
AND ALSO ENGAGING IN SURVIVAL --
SOCKS -- AND
IN ART WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE ARE KIDS ARE NOT BEING
TRAFFICKED AND SO OBVIOUSLY THE
ISSUE GOES WELL BEYOND THE LGBT
COMMUNITY BUT THERE IS A
SPECIFIC --
NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR MORE
SUPPORT AND SO I THANK THE
AUTHOR OF FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION.
FOR THANK YOU.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO SENATOR MITCHELL
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUE IN
WOMEN'S CAUCUS RESOLUTION TO A
AN SR.
ELEVEN A MAJESTIC KNOWLEDGE HOW
PROUD I AM OF THE WORK THAT THIS
BODY DID A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
MILLION WHEN WE MOVED --
TO DECRIMINALIZE PROSTITUTION
FOR VICTIMS OF SEX TRAFFICKING
ONLY LOOKED BACK AT THE RECORD
TO RECOGNIZE HOW MANY ALL MORE
CAUGHT UP.
IN THE LEGAL SYSTEM --
AB FOR NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN AND
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT
THEY INDEED ARE VICTIMS AND
DESERVE OUR PROTECTION AND
SHOULD BE TREATED AS SUCH.
AND FOR ALL THOSE REASONS I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SR.
ELEVEN THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
PROTEIN MACHEN'S THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT A ON DOG.
I RISE TODAY ALSO AS A MEMBER OF
THE WOMEN'S --
CAUCUS THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
KERR CORD --
AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER
SPEAKERS ON THIS RESOLUTION.
BUT I DON'T THINK I CAN
UNDERSCORE A KNOCK OFF HOW
SERIOUS IT IS AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES --
FORCING DIEGO I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IN OF A KNOWLEDGE THE
WORK OF THE JUNIOR LEAGUE AND I
KNOW IT'S A BIG ISSUE THAT THEY
HAVE STATEWIDE.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE HAVE NO
CLUE.
HOW INSIDIOUS THIS ISSUE IS?
AND THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT IT
IMPACTS FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE
AND UNTIL YOU HEAR THE STORIES.
ARE YOU JUST IT'S ALMOST
UNIMAGINABLE AND IT WAS FOR ME I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE POINT
LOMA NAZARENE COLLEGE THEY DID --
FOR OUR COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO A
STUDY TO TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS IMPACTED --
THE PEOPLE BROUGHT INTO --
THAT LIFE AND IT WAS LARGER THAN
THE SIZE OF ONE OF MY CITIES DEL
MAR.
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS WELL OVER
TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE DIRECTLY.
IMPACTED IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CAPTION THAT --
HAVE THREE OF OUR GREATEST
CITIES LA SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
DIEGO ON THE FBI LIST OF THE
THIRD OF THE THIRTEEN CITIES IN
AMERICA AS HOT SPOTS FOR SEX
TRAFFICKING.
AND THAT DOESN'T EVEN GET INTO
LABOR TRAFFICKING WHICH WE HAVE
YET TO REALLY HAVE A FULL
DISCUSSION ABOUT HERE.
IN THIS STATE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WE UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH EDUCATION THERE IS
STILL TO DO EVEN WITH THE
LEGISLATION MENTIONED BY MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN HILLS --
IN ADDITION TO SOME LEGISLATION
MANY OF US HAVE ALSO CARRIED OFF
HOW TO HELP --
WORKERS IN THE HOTEL MOTEL
INDUSTRY WHO WERE ON THE FRONT
LINES -- OF
BEING ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND USE
THEM AND THEIR EXPERTISE AS
RESOURCES AND ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE
THEM TO REPORT IT AND APPLAUD
THEM WHEN THEY DO.
MUCH LIKE THE STORIES WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE AIRLINE --
FLIGHT ATTENDANT WHO RECOGNIZE
SOMETHING AND REPORTED IT.
THE DRIVER I CAN'T REMEMBER IF
IT WAS UBER OR LIFT BUT ONE OF
THE DRIVERS WHO NOTICED AND TOOK
ACTION WE NEED TO GIVE FULL
PERMISSION TO EACH AND EVERYONE --
IN OUR SOCIETY TO PAY IT AND THE
MORE EDUCATION WE DO THE BETTER --
WE WILL BE ABLE TO CONFRONT THIS
REALLY HORRIBLE SITUATION WE
HAVE TO TREAT THIS AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY EMERGENCY THAT
IT IS WHEN THERE ARE MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IDENTIFIED
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
THAT IS JUST UNACCEPTABLE
UNACCEPTABLE AND WE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WE ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE AND I APPLAUD --
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD
THIS RESOLUTION --
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THIS
EVERY DAY IN TERMS OF THE LAWS
THAT IT IMPACTS I URGE ALSO OF
COURSE WHAT I THINK WILL BE.
A UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR SR
ELEVEN BUT WE NEED TO CARRY IT
FORWARD BEYOND TODAY AND I THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM.
SENATORS IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
SEEN HEARING NINE CENTER LEVEL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND IF WE REMAINED
DILIGENT AS IKNOW WE ALL WILL
WE REALLY CAN ERADICATE THIS
REAL CRISIS THAT WE HAVE GOING
ON IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I REGION I VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
AYE.
I BILL.
I FOR JUST. FIVE BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
BY DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE FURTADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
I LIVE A BY [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED I'M REAL
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY HAND [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
BY RUBIO STERN [inaudible]
BY KATHY [inaudible]
WILK. FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE FINAL ITEM
TWENTY DAYS.
DOCKET THAT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SENATOR JACKSON'S PREPARED
TO PRESENT MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWELVE BY
SENATOR JACKSON RELATIVE TO THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
SANTA BARBARA OIL SPILL CENTER
JACKSON THE FLOOR IS YOURS THING
THIS PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES FIFTY
YEARS AGO FIFTY YEARS AGO TODAY.
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY EXPERIENCED
WHAT WAS THEN THE WORST OIL
SPILL.
IN THIS NATION'S HISTORY. FIFTY
YEARS LATER IT REMAINS.
THE THIRD MOST SIGNIFICANT OIL
SPILL IN THIS NATION'S HISTORY
THIRD ONLY TO THE EXXON VALDEZ.
AND PLATFORM HORIZON IN.
NEW ORLEANS IN LOUISIANA.
I RISE TODAY. TO PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION COMMEMORATING THAT
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE ORAL
SPILL WHICH BEGAN ON JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BUT
CONTINUED FOR WEEKS.
AND THEN MONTHS THERE AFTER.
SPILLING AN ESTIMATED THREE TO
FOUR MILLION GALLONS OF CRUDE
OIL.
ALONG THE COAST OF SANTA BABARA
DOWN THROUGH A GREAT PORTION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT COMPLETELY DESTROYED AND TO
SPOIL THE COASTLINE KILLED
THOUSANDS OF MARINE LIFE AND
WILDLIFE.
AND CREATED WHAT TURNED OUT TO
BE ON THE POSITIVE SIDE.
THE BEGINNING OF THE MODERN
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT.
NOW.
A NEWLY DRILLED WELL FROM
PLATFORM A IN SANTA BARBARA.
BECAUSE THIS FIRE EXCUSE ME THE
OIL WELL.
IT FAILED CONTAINMENT.
THUS BEGINNING THE SURGE OF
THOSE MILLIONS OF GALLONS.
IT FAILED BECAUSE THE OPERATOR
AT THAT TIME UNION OIL.
WAS MORE INTERESTED IN SECURING
A FEDERAL WAIVER TO AVOID SAFETY
REGULATIONS SUCH AS REQUIREMENTS
FOR STEEL CASING REINFORCEMENT
THAT COULD HAVE PREVENTED.
THIS TRAGEDY IT WAS MORE
INTERESTED IN THAT THEN IT WAS
INTERESTED IN PROPERLY SECURING
ITS WELL.
AN ACTUAL RESULT WE SAW THIS
DEVASTATION. TO OUR ECONOMY TO
OUR NATURAL RESOURCE AND TO THE
WILDLIFE.
AND TO THE BIRDS AND OTHER
SANCTUARY.
OF THE CREATURES THAT WE AS
STEWARDS OF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE PRESERVING
AND PROTECTING.
AND WHAT WE DO THOUGH.
IS WE RESPONDED WE CREATED
GRASSROOTS ACTIVISM GIVING RISE
TO NEW ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
VENERABLE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER.
GET OIL OUT WHICH WE
AFFECTIONATELY CALL BLOOM.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT EXISTS TO
THIS DAY AND THE COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL COUNCIL AMONG
OTHER GROUPS.
THIS BEGAN THE BEGINNING OF
BIRTHDAY.
AND HOPEFULLY.
AS WE LOOK PROACTIVELY INTO THE
FUTURE WE WILL RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS.
THAT WE ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
THAT WE REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCE ON
OIL WHETHER RICH --
DRILLED OFFSHORE OR ON SURE
MAINTENANCE THAT THIS STATE HAS
LED THE NATION.
IN SEEKING TO ACHIEVE TO BECOME.
OUR ENERGY INDEPENDENT USING
ALTERNATIVE CLEAN ENERGY SOURCES
THAT WE STOP BACKSLIDING THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE CLIMATE CHANGES IN
MANY INSTANCES THE RESULT OF
BURNING OF THESE FOSSIL FUELS.
AND I NOTE I MENTION DEBRIS FLOW
AND FIRE.
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS
ALSO AFFECTED MY COMMUNITY AND
LIKELY MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AS WE LOOK FORWARD WE ARE
SEEING THAT THE MIDDLE OF THIS
COUNTRY THIS WEEK WILL BE
EXPERIENCING THE COLDEST WEATHER.
THAT IT HAS EXPERIENCED IN
DECADES IF WE DO NOT REALIZE THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF FOSSIL
FUELS IN THAT MEASURE THAT WE
ARE DESTINED TO REPEAT THESE
PROBLEMS.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS
RESOLUTION AND STRONGLY AFFIRM A
TRULY CALIFORNIA LEGACY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION THAT
THE GOOD PEOPLE OF SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY IN MANY COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP
TO PROMOTE AND TO ADVANCE AS A
RESULT OF THIS HORRIFIC EVENT
THAT OCCURRED FIFTY YEARS AGO
TODAY I ASKED FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
SENATORS WE LIKE VERY CEDARS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
SENATOR STERN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I I
RISE TODAY --
TECHNOLOGY FAMILIES THAT ARE IN
THE BUILDING THEY'RE NOT WITH US
HERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY WE JUST.
I'M SO SORRY CENTER WE'RE GONNA.
BUDGET THE FLOOR RIGHT AFTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WITNESSES SENATOR ON THIS ITEM
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
SHE WOULD NOT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
HI BELL. FIVE FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG.
BY DOT [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
BY WITH SOME.
HIGH --
TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LABOR.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BOB I COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
THAT'S ATKINS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
WHAT COUNTY [inaudible]
WILK.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS ONE THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SENATORS WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR AND RECOGNIZE SENATOR
STERN AT HIS DESK.
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISS PRESENT POLICIES.
FOR AT ORDER COMMENTS A MOMENT
AGO -- WE
JUST FINISHED.
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR --
THE VICTIMS OF THE BORDERLINE
SHOOTING --
WHICH OCCURRED --
LAST NOVEMBER AND THOUSAND OAKS
COUNTRY MUSIC BAR --
IN A QUIET LITTLE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT NO ONE EVER
THOUGHT ANYTHING LIKE THIS WOULD
HAPPEN --
THE TWELVE FAMILIES AND
SURVIVING THE VICTIMS ARE HERE
TODAY.
THEY THE THEY'RE A LITTLE
EXHAUSTED AFTER THE LAST ROUND
OF MORAL IS ASIAN IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
HAVING BEEN THRUST INTO THE
SPOTLIGHT NATIONALLY IS NOT
SOMETHING PEOPLE ASK FOR WHEN WE
WORK IN OUR LINE OF WORK MAYBE
WE WE SEEK IT OR WE WE AT LEAST
UNDERSTAND IT'S A PART OF THE
THE JOB BUT THESE FAMILIES --
YEAH THEY'RE LIVING THEIR LIVES --
AND NOW THEY'VE.
BEEN PUT INTO A A SPOTLIGHT THAT
THAT THEY NEVER WANTED OR ASK
FOR A YOUNG MAN WHO --
I WON'T NAME --
BUT WAS A MARINE --
VETERANS --
WHO GREW UP IN THE COMMUNITY AND
WENT OFF?
AND CME HOME WITH SOME DAMAGE.
AND HAD LEFT WITH SOME DAMAGE.
TO CAME BACK ON HEALED IN --
AND HINGED.
AND WALKED INTO A BAR THAT NIGHT
AND TOOK THE LIVES OF WELL
PEOPLE AT THEY CAN NEVER BE
TAKEN BACK --
THESE MOMENTS ARE STRANGE
BECAUSE THEY DEFY POLITICS --
IN FACT --
MOST OF FAMILIES.
WHO WHO WERE HARMED THEM MOST
THE MOST THE KIDS WHO WERE THERE
THAT NIGHT?
OF PRIDE IN VOTE FOR ME --
AND DON'T REALLY REALLY CARE TOO
MUCH ABOUT --
THIS LINE TO WORKING --
WHEN WE DO THIS JOB THOUGH WE
SORT OF NEED TO TRANSCEND OUR
STATION IN THESE MOMENTS?
AND TRY TO FIND SOME WAY TO HOLD
OTHERS PAIN.
AND I JUST. FOR THOSE OF YOU OF
ALL BEEN THROUGH THESE.
THESE INCIDENTS YOU REALIZE THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE SMALL --
BUT OUR OUR PURPOSE HERE IS
HUMBLE.
AND WE JUST HAVE TO BE VESSELS
OF HEALING FOR THESE COMMUNITIES
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND
THESE FAMILIES ARE TRYING.
TO DIVINE THEIR PURPOSE IN THIS
MOMENT.
OF HOW TO TAKE THAT TRAGEDY IN
PAVE IT INTO SOME KIND OF
GREATER GREATER --
THING IN JUST MORNING BECAUSE
IT'S TOO MUCH THIS MORNING WHEN
YOU LOSE YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER OR
LOSE YOUR MOM OR YOUR HUSBAND --
IN THIS KID OF HUESO.
OUT WILL WILL BE LOOKING BACK TO
TO THIS TRAGEDY AS THE YEAR GOES
ON BUT JUST FOR TODAY --
I WANTED KNOWLEDGE THEM I KNOW A
PAPERWORK [inaudible]
THANK GOD.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY IF I COULD.
I'M GONNA READ THEIR NAMES YOU
ONE BY.
ONE THE SERGEANT RON HE WAS AGE.
FIFTY FOUR RESIDE IN MORE PARK
AND HE WAS A SERGEANT AT VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE WHO.
WENT INTO THE SHOOTING.
ABOUT AWAY.
WHEN INTO THE FIRE [inaudible]
SHAWN ADLER.
SIMI VALLEY AGE.
FORTY EIGHT THE OWN THE RECENTLY
OPENED RIVALRY ROASTERS.
A LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
CODY GIFFORD KAUFMAN.
AGE TWENTY TWO GROUPING CAM
MARIA [inaudible]
IS THE SON OF A MANUAL COME TO
KNOW WHO HAD HIS BOY EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD.
AND RAISE THEM AS SINGLE FATHER.
AND LOS IS THERE'S ONLY
TREASURED SON --
LAKE DINGHY.
LIKE THE MOON AND AND JAKE DONE --
WERE BEST FRIENDS THERE THAT
NIGHT.
AND WASN'T SET ON THE ASSEMBLY
FOR BUT THEY CAME UP WITH.
THE CATCH PHRASE HOLDER WIDE
THERE -- OFF
ROADERS AND THEY SPENT THE A RUN
AROUND HILLS BY CHECK CRAZY
VEHICLES IN FIXING CARS AND
INCREDIBLY YOUNG MEN --
NOW WITH US.
ELENA HOUSLEY WAS EIGHTEEN YEARS
OLD.
GREW UP IN NAPA CITY PEPPERDINE
UNIVERSITY. EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
FULL LIGHT GORE.
THURMOND RE QUE.
A MARINE HIMSELF AGE
[inaudible] THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND OAKS.
HE STARTED A NON PROFIT --
CALLED TEAM RED WHITE AND BLUE
AND I ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
LOOK HIM UP.
THEY DO SOME INCREDIBLE WORK
WITH VETERANS.
AND HEALING THROUGH THROUGH
RACES AND RIDING.
JUST TO MEET.
WHO IS ENDEAVOR TO JOIN OUR --
OUR ARMED SERVICES BUT WAS
ACTUALLY --
STUDY SECURITY IT TALU THROWN IN
HIS MOM AND DAD GAVE ME AN ESSAY
HE WROTE.
ABOUT THE SECURITY CHALLENGE WE
HAVE IT SMALL PLACES LIKE THE
BORDERLINE.
AND JUST WEEKS BEFORE IT
FINISHED HIS THESIS AND TALKED
ABOUT THE RISKS. TO TO PLACES
LIKE THIS BEING VICTIMS OF MASS
SHOOTINGS.
JUST LOST HIS LIFE.
AND MARK MAY IS A AGE TWENTY
GROUP IN CARPINTERIA USE
EMPLOYEE THERE IS MINE IS
BUSINESS FRIENDLY WAS JOB.
JUST LIKE CRISTINA MORISSETTE
AGE TWENTY WITHIN SEAMY VALLEY
ALSO EMPLOYEE.
A LOVELY DAUGHTER.
BRIMMING WITH PRIDE AND HER
FAMILY'S HERE TODAY TOO AND
TELLER FINALS AGE.
TWENTY SEVEN ALSO A NAVY VETERAN.
BELOVED SON AND A BROTHER AND A
FRIEND.
AND FINALLY NO WELL SPARKS AGE
TWENTY ONE SO MORE POOR COLLEGE
STUDENT MEMBER LOCAL CHURCH.
AND A SHINING LIGHT.
I WILL GOON ANY FURTHER BUT I
JUST ASK THAT WE HUMBLY JOURNAL
THEIR MEMORY AND ALL THOSE
OTHERS WHO LOSE THEIR LIVES YOU
KNOW.
HOLD OUR CELL SMALL TRY TO REACH
REACH DEEPER IN OURSELVES AND
BEYOND OUR STATION.
TRY TO HEAL LITTLE THROUGH THIS
IMPORTANT WORK WE DO THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
AND IT'S A VERY GOOD POINT --
IF YOU IF YOU WOULD JOIN ME --
I'D ASK FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
IF WE CAN HAVE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
ALONG WITH INDIVIDUALS IN THE
GALLERY [inaudible]
PLEASE RISE. FOR A MOMENT OF
SILENCE
.
STERN ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
PLEASE SEND OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILIES WHO
ARE HERE TODAY. TO THOSE WHO ARE
AT HOME. ONE OF THE MOST TRAGIC
EVENTS IN MODERN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO STAY WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL INTRODUCTION
BY CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY TODAY
WE HAVE THE NORTH ORANGE COUNTY.
NORTH ORANGE COAST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
SERVES A POPULATION OF OVER ONE
MILLION PEOPLE.
THE ECONOMY WORKS ENHANCER
EMPLOYEES POTENTIAL IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE STUDENT SUCCESS WON THE
PROGRAM EMPLOYEES DEVELOP
INDIVIDUAL STRATEGIES TO GROW
THEIR SKILLS AS LEADERS AB.
EDUCATORS AND COMMUNICATORS.
IS YOUR ONLY THIRTY EMPLOYEES
ARE MAJOR TO THE ECONOMY AFTER A
COMPETITIVE APPLICATION PROCESS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO CELEBRATE ALL OF
THEIR HARD WORK THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
LAW FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
WE NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY JOURNEY
MEMORIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED TO PRO TO MACINNES
OFFICE OR THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
OFFICE.
AT THIS TIME.
SO WITH THAT IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS.
MAJORITY LEADER THE DESK IS
CLEAR [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE RIVER MUCH WAS PRESENT
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY TODAY.
AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WE MADE WE WILL RECONVENE ON
THURSDAY THURSDAY AT NINE AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
MAJORITY LEADER OF THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME THE
JOURNEY MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE THIS COMING
THURSDAY AT NINE AM HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEK SENATORS THANK
YOU